Speaker 1: Donald Trump exploded on his own.
Former Attorney General William Barr calling him
a gutless pig because William Barr gave a sober
and sensible legal analysis which indicated the
indictment against Trump is very serious. Trump's
early arguments about how other presidents did
the same thing aren't very good and that Trump is
toast if even half of the indictment is accurate.
In response, Donald Trump losing his mind on troth
essential posting, quote Virtually everyone is
saying that the Capital I indictment is about
election interference and should not have been
brought except Bill Barr, a disgruntled former
employee and lazy attorney general who was weak
and totally ineffective. He doesn't mean what he's
saying. It's just misinformation. Barr's doing
it because he hates Trump for firing him. He was
deathly afraid of the radical left when they said
they would impeach him. He knows the indictment
is bull. Turn off Fox News when that gutless pig
is on. And again, when you listen to what William
Barr says and then you see that Trump rebuts none
of the actual legal claims and Trump is not a
lawyer and Trump has no idea what's being said
in this particular case. Doesn't mean you
have to like either of them. I believe
William Barr William Barr's analysis comes
much closer to getting to the heart of this
indictment than does Trump's. Which
is it was election interference and
I did nothing wrong. After the break, we will
look at Lindsey Graham subjected to just very
light questioning about these issues. Wild,
wild stuff. Quick break and back with that